Speaker 1: You know, we really had this
virus on the ropes for a little while there,
but it has come back really
strongly. It has fought its way back,
mostly through the unvaccinated, through the
unmasked. And we now have listened to this
three times, the average daily cases of one
year ago and close to twice the daily deaths
of one year ago. We're going to go through
the numbers here. And this is building
on yesterday's segment about scientists aren't
sure about the future of this pandemic when the
end is going to be later today. Joe Biden is going
to be addressing the nation and announcing a bunch
of new initiatives, including a vaccination
requirement for every single federal worker
that is going to be met with some resistance for
sure. And we are going to look at the numbers,
which are also making it very difficult to guess
about the end of the pandemic. So as reported by a
whole bunch of different news outlets daily, U.S.
covid case is up for more than 300 percent from
Labor Day last year. Daily coronavirus cases are
four times higher than they were following Labor
Day weekend. It really seems closer to three
now that the numbers have kind of shaken out
the number of daily deaths twice as high. It's
almost twice as high, about 70 percent higher
based on data from Johns Hopkins University.
So let's look at the actual numbers here.
Cases per day in the United States are now 300
percent higher, three times higher. We could say
it might actually be even worse. We're still
getting data from Labor Day weekend and some
states are now reporting really slowly in terms of
deaths. Deaths are now 70 percent higher per day
than they were a year ago. And again, like with
cases actually even more so, we are still getting
data from the last 10 days in terms of deaths.
Some states like Florida now reporting deaths
on a huge delay to always make their most recent
numbers look better. I explained that mechanism to
last week in terms of vaccination. Those numbers
are not looking so good. We are really stagnant on
vaccination. We are still now in September
of twenty twenty one, just a hair over 53
percent, fifty three point two percent fully
vaccinated in the United States. And when you look
at other countries, if you look at at least one
dose, the U.S. is at 63 percent. We are way, way,
way behind so many countries, including the United
Arab Emirates, Portugal, Qatar, Singapore, Spain,
Chile, Ireland, Canada, Belgium, France, the U.K.,
Italy, Bahrain, the Netherlands, Cambodia, all
of these countries with more first doses than the
United States. And that is particularly depressing
when you consider that we had essentially a full
supply of vaccines, meaning if you want a vaccine,
you go and get one. We had a full supply much
earlier than just about every single one of
those other countries. Now, for those saying,
you know, David, sir, cases don't matter if
people aren't getting sick, if people aren't
getting hospitalized. Well, I already told you,
deaths are up 70 percent, but hospitalizations
are also way up compared to a year ago.
Hospitalizations are about 300 percent higher,
around 100000. We only had about 30000 people
hospitalized with covid a year ago. So what are
the indicators in our favor, if there are any?
One is that relative to cases, deaths aren't
as high. And what I mean by that is deaths.
When we had this level of cases previously,
deaths were higher, cases are up 300 percent,
but deaths are only up 70 percent. That means
each case is less likely to lead to death because
half the country is now vaccinated. But of course,
too many people are not. And then maybe, you know,
we aren't sure yet. The cases are leveling
off. The hospitalizations are leveling off,
and we can hope that we're going to start
to see a decline there. But at this point,
the additional complexity is how much of that
leveling off is because of the reporting delays
in general and because of Labor Day weekend? We
just don't know yet. So the situation could be
dramatically better than it is. I will be
live streaming later today if you you know,
it'll probably be an hour after the show publishes
today. But Joe Biden will announce a six pronged
new strategy for fighting the virus. It will
reportedly include from what's been reported
by CNN's Caitlin Collins so far. It will include
a full vaccine mandate for all federal workers.
That's a lot of agencies across the country.
The reaction to. That is going to be, oh,
this is tyranny, and of course it's not,
but the situation is not looking good and
we must. I feel morally required to follow up
about ivermectin. So let's talk about that next.